IN A GENTLE REMINDER THAT WAR IS
NOT A GAME OF YACHTS EIGHTH, A
MILITARY FIGURE SET OF ISIS
FIGURES DON'T SURRENDER, BEAT
THEM TO DEATH WITH A SHOVEL.
I THINK I NEED TO LIE DOWN.
KILL THE ENEMY?
WHAT ARE WE, MONSTROUS?
IN HIS FACEBOOK POST, SENIOR
ENLISTED ADVISOR TO THE CHAIRMAN
OF JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFF ARMY
COMMAND SERGEANT MAJOR
JOHN WAYNE TROXELL, WROTE "IF
DETAINING FACILITY SELF, PROVIDE
THEM WITH CHILD, HE COCKED, AND
DUE PROCESS.
HOWEVER, IF THEY CHOOSE NOT TO
SURRENDER, THEN WE WILL KILL
THEM WITH EXTREME PREJUDICE
BOMBS ON THEM, SHOOTING THEM IN
THE FACE.
THAT'S NEVER GOOD.
OR BEATING THEM TO DEATH WITH
OUR ENTRENCHING TOOLS."
FINALLY SOMETHING ON FACEBOOK
THAT ISN'T ABOUT YOUR KIDS
BIRTHDAY POEM.
IF THIS OFFENDS YOU, YOU ARE --
IT'S THAT SENSIBILITY THAT WINS
WARS.
WE PUT GUYS LIKE TROXELL OUT
THERE TO HOLD THE LINE.
THEN WE JUMP ON OUR HIGH HORSES
WE CATCH A GLIMPSE OF WHAT THEY
HAVE TO DO.
ANY OBJECTION TO THIS BOILS DOWN
TO "WE KILL BAD GUYS IN WAR?
I HAD NO IDEA."
COURSE YOU DID.
YOU WANT TO PRETEND YOU DON'T SO
YOU CAN HOLD THE MORAL HIGH
GROUND.
AS THE SAYING GOES, IT'S EASY TO
BE A HOLY MAN IN THE MOUNTAINS
ARE IN THE HOLLYWOOD HILLS.
WE COULD USE MORE OF THIS
ADVICE, NOT LESS.
IF THIS MAN IS GUNNING FOR, I
MIGHT HAVE TO BREAK OUT MY
SHOVEL.
ABC SAID THIS KIND OF COMMENT
RAISED EYEBROWS.
I LIKE THAT PHRASE.
IT RAISED EYEBROWS.
>> Dana: IS LIKE SAYING IT'S
INTERESTING.
I LOVE THAT HIS NAME IS
JOHN WAYNE.
HE WAS MEANT TO BE A SOLDIER.
I CAN'T BELIEVE PEOPLE
COMPLAINED ABOUT THIS.
>> Greg: IT'S NEWS, THAT'S
WHAT'S INTERESTING TO ME.
I WOULD LOVE TO ASK THE ISIS
GUYS WHAT THEY THOUGHT OF WHEN
THEY WERE RAPING WOMEN, THEY ARE
WHO WON'T SURRENDER.
KILLING THEM BRUTALLY WITH A
SHOVEL.
>> Dana: THEY DO THAT SO WE
DON'T HAVE TO THINK ABOUT IT.
>> Juan: HERE'S THE REAL NEWS.
I SIT HERE EVERY NIGHT AT 5:00
AND YOU TELL ME PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS ANNIHILATED, DEFEATED,
CLEARED OUT.
THEY ARE GONE.
HERE COMES JOHN WAYNE TROXELL
AND SAYS WE ARE STILL FIGHTING.
THIS FIGHT IS NOT OVER.
>> Greg: NO ONE SAID IT WAS
OVER.
>> Juan: YOU TOLD AMERICA.
>> Greg: IT'S AN EXISTENTIAL
THREAT.
>> Juan: IT CONTINUES AND
MORPHS AND GOES INTO ONLINE
THREATS AND OTHER COUNTRIES.
THEY GO TO AFRICA, THE
PHILIPPINES.
HERE'S THE OTHER THING THAT CAME
OUT THIS WEEK AND I THINK WHY
THIS COMMENT IS SO INSENSITIVE
EVEN FOR OUR WARRIORS.
BECAUSE AP REPORTS 11,000
CIVILIANS DIED IN THE EFFORT --
>> Greg: HE IS SAYING KILLING
ISIS.
>> Juan: WE WANT TO PROTECT
CIVILIANS BUT IF YOU GO ABOUT IT
IN A GROSS MANNER WHERE YOU ARE
SAYING WE ARE GOING TO
ANNIHILATE.
>> Greg: IT IS INSENSITIVE TO
>> Juan: YOU SAY COME ON.
>> Greg: THERE IS NO
RELATIVISM.
DON'T SAY OUR MILITARY MEN ARE
WE ARE GOING TO ATTACK YOU IN A
SLOPPY, GROSS MANNER.
>> Jesse: SLOPPY IS
YOU KNOW WHAT'S REALLY NEAT AND
TIDY?
KNOCKING SOMEONE IN THE HEAD
WITH A SHOVEL.
NO CIVILIAN CASUALTIES.
CASUALTIES.
ONE-ON-ONE.
I AM SICK OF LISTENING -- UNDER
THEY WERE PLAYING SOCCER.
WE WERE GIVING THEM VIDEO TAPES,
MOVIES.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT THEIR LAST
RITES.
LEAVE THEM DEAD IN THE STREETS.
IT'S FINALLY TIME TO DO IT AND
YOU'VE SEEN THE RESULTS.
THEY HAVE UNCOCKED THE MILITARY.
THERE HAS BEEN CIVILIAN
CASUALTIES AND THAT'S HORRIBLE
BUT BY NOT DOING ANYTHING ON THE
GROUND OVER THERE, IT'S GOING TO
CAUSE MORE CIVILIAN CASUALTIES.
>> Greg: CIVILIAN CASUALTIES
WILL BE REDUCE THE MORE WE USE
DRONES.
WE WILL BE ABLE TO AVOID
CIVILIANS.
CIVILIANS DIED BECAUSE THE
TERRORISTS ARE USING THEM AS
SHIELDS.
KIMBERLY, MAKE THIS AS ELEGANT
ABOUT A SOLDIER WHO BEHEADED A
JIHADI AND CAUGHT OFF HIS ARMS
AND USED IT TO BEAT THE OTHER
TERRORISTS.
>> Jesse: ELOQUENCE.
>> Kimberly: MY POINT IS WAR
IS WAR, AND PEOPLE ARE TALKING
ABOUT -- THAT'S MY KIND OF WAR
STORY.
PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT RAISING
EYEBROWS.
THEY ARE CUTTING OFF HEADS AND
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT US.
THEY HAVE NO CIVILITY
WHATSOEVER.
RAPE, PILLAGING, BEHEADING.
GLOBAL TERRORISM.
THE LEASE WE ARE DOING SOMETHING
ABOUT IT.
WE HAVE RETURNED THE RULES OF
ENGAGEMENT TO WHAT THEY
SHOULD'VE BEEN BEFORE AND WHAT
THEY WERE PRIOR TO THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND THE YOUNG
AND THE PRESIDENT IS LISTENING
TO THEM.
HOW REFRESHING.
GUESS WHAT THAT'S PRODUCING?
RESULTS.
>> Greg: DID YOU HEAR THIS
STORY ABOUT THE GITMO DETAINEES
WHO ARE JUMPING ON THE "ME TOO"
ISSUE.
THEY CLAIM THEY ARE BEING
SEXUALLY HARASSED BECAUSE THEY
ARE FRISKED BEFORE GOING INTO
COURT.
>> Jesse: NO ONE CARES.
NO ONE IS INTERESTED.
>> Juan: THERE WERE NEW PEOPLE
PUT IN PLACE AND THEY HAD NEW
WAYS OF CONDUCTING SEARCHES.
ACTUALLY THE COURT SAID THEY
I MUST SAY IF WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT LANGUAGE ON THIS.
>> Kimberly: HAVE YOU GONE
THROUGH TSA THESE DAYS?